♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WILL GET A LOT OF
WORK ON THIS PROGRAM TO EXPOSE
THE BIAS AND CORRUPTION AT
GOOGLE WHICH IS THE WORLD'S MOST
POWERFUL COMPANY, BY FAR.
GOOGLE AND DOMINIC DOESN'T JUST
HAVE IT OUT FOR CONSERVATIVES.
GOOGLE IS HOSTILE TO ANYONE WHO
CHALLENGES THE STATUS QUO.
JUST AFTER THE FIRST
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE, WHERE
GABBERT WAS THE MOST SEARCHED
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
SHE'S THE FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE TO SUE GOOGLE.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: TELL US THE POINT
OF THIS SUIT.
>> HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
UNCHECKED POWER THAT THESE BIG
TECH MONOPOLIES HAVE OVER OUR
PUBLIC DISCOURSE AND HOW THIS IS
A REAL THREAT TO OUR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND TO OUR ELECTION.
WE'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND HERE
THAT GOOGLE CAN DO THIS TO ME
COME AS A SITTING MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, RUNNING FOR THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND.
IF THAT MEANS THEY CAN DO THIS
TO ANY CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR ANY
OFFICE ANYWHERE IN THIS COUNTRY,
AND FRANKLY TO ANY PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
THAT WHETHER YOU ARE A
PROGRESSIVE OR CONSERVATIVE,
WHETHER YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF ON
THE LEFT OR THE RIGHT, WE ALL
HAVE TO STAND UNITED TO PROTECT
OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
BECAUSE, LOOK, TODAY, TOMORROW,
IT COULD BE YOU OR SOMEONE ELSE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
GOD BLESS YOU BY THE WAY.
WHY ARE YOU THE ONLY CANDIDATE
WHO SAYING THIS QUESTION MARKS
THE GO I CAN EXPLAIN THAT
TUCKER, BUT I DO KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE PROTECT
OUR FREEDOMS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S SOMETHING, I THINK THAT
PEOPLE TAKE FOR GRANTED UNLESS
THEY ARE THE ONES UNDER ATTACK.
THESE FREEDOMS ARE ENSHRINED IN
OUR CONSTITUTION.
I LOVE OUR COUNTRY, I LOVE OUR
PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHY I'M STANDING UP AND
FIGHTING FOR THESE FREEDOMS,
EVEN WHEN THESE FREEDOMS ALLOW
THOSE WHO SAY THINGS I MAY
DISAGREE WITH, TO HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO DO SO.
THESE ARE THE PRINCIPLES I STAND
UP FOR IT, THAT EVEN YOU AND I
MAY DISAGREE ON THINGS, I'M
WILLING TO GIVE MY LIFE FOR YOUR
FREEDOM TO DO SO.
>> Tucker: SO, YOU FILED THIS
LAWSUIT, AND GOD BLESS YOU FOR
DOING THAT.
WHAT SHOULD MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
DO?
SPEAK OF WASHINGTON NEEDS TO
ACT.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT GOOGLE,
FACEBOOK, TWITTER.
THESE ARE BIG TECH MONOPOLIES
THAT HAVE THIS UNCHECKED POWER
TO INFLUENCE OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE, TO INFLUENCE WHAT
KIND OF INFORMATION PEOPLE ARE
SEEN.
GOOGLE IS IN CONTROL OF 88% OF
ALL INTERNET SEARCHES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I BELIEVE IT'S 92% OF ALL
INTERNET SEARCHES IN THE WORLD.
SO GOOGLE IS CONTROLLING, WHEN
YOU TYPE INTO THAT GOOGLE SEARCH
BOX, WHAT POPS UP.
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU SEE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT CONGRESS
TAKES ACTION, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THIS IS UNCHECKED.
IF GOT THEIR SECRET ALGORITHMS.
THEY CAN CONTROL THE INFORMATION
THAT WE SEE.
THEY CAN CONTROL WHAT POPS UP IN
OUR FIRST       FACEBOOK FEE.
THEY CAN CENSOR THINGS THEY
DISAGREE WITH.
GOOGLE HAS A SHOT OUT THOSE WHO
HAVE NOT BROKEN ANY OF THEIR
TERMS OF USE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CONGRESS TAKES ACTION TO PROVIDE
THIS OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY'S, AND ULTIMATELY
TO BREAK UP THESE BIG TECH
MONOPOLIES.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU GOING TO
BRING THIS UP IN THE DEBATES
THIS WEEK?
>> I LOOK FORWARD TO DOING SO.
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT IS INTEGRAL.
WE ALL MUST STAND UP AND
PROTECT.
WE WANT SO IMPORTANT.
I SPOKE TO    TO A RIGHT WINGERT
I SPOKE TO    TO A RIGHT WINGERD
I SPOKE TO    TO A RIGHT WINGERY